you've heard the phrase embarrassment of
riches
that's what new york has if you replace
riches with awful horrible no good liars
in power who ruined people's lives and
let people die
or you could just call them new york
democrats first there's the governor
whose staff admits to covering up rest
home deaths
in a just world cuomo would be out but
we also know he has a brother at cnn
so when the rest rest home story
worsened what did his comedic sidekick
do
tweet at republicans sadly he kept the
giant q-tip at home
in his prop closet with the ankle
weights just an fyi none of those
republicans were responsible for
thousands of dead
and so today as the governor feels the
heat he took the stage
whose fault could this be
kovid did not get into the nursing homes
by people coming from hospitals covert
got into the nursing homes
by staff walking into the nursing home
when we didn't even know we had covert
anybody can bring it in
a delivery man brings it in the heating
repair man brings it in
the food service brings it in staff
person goes home has
meets with their family someone in the
family has it staff member comes back
the staff member brings it in
see it's just not his fault it's all
those little people but you gotta wonder
how does he know this i mean he blamed
all of this on a void of information
which is funny given who controls the
information it's him
how can you forget this we're below the
national average
in number of deaths in nursing homes but
who
cares 33 28
died in a hospital died in a nursing
home
they died as bad as cuomo
is and he's bad he has one ace in the
hole
an acehole so to speak known as bill de
blasio
his crime not only rises but turns
grizzly under him
this weekend a fiend stabs four kills
two that had been recently arrested for
at least
four other violent attacks why was he on
the street
well maybe he'd get coven in prison but
where's
where cuomo's defense is always steeped
in defensive arrogance
de blasio is always mindless ambivalence
knowing disorder accelerates the
revolution
and the bre and the press plays on and
so as new york bleeds out
people pack the u-hauls leaving the rich
and the insane behind
maybe they can fight it out i'm sure the
tickets for that show
will be easier to get than hamilton
so uh dana i'd like to see your
perspective from the public relations
point of view
given that that is your history how do
you think this thing went today with
cuomo
well not well and i would say that um
presidential ambitions are out the
window
and i also think that his hopes of a
fourth term as governor
are done and i think if he announces
that sooner than later
uh that will probably help because he's
not just taking incoming
from the right he's now taking incoming
from the left
and if you think about one of the worst
things that happened at the beginning of
the pandemic was him
fighting with de blasio yeah um and and
waiting you know and sort of wasting
time
um i would say that if you're going to
have a press conference like this
one why didn't you do it last thursday
when this story broke
the story now has been out there
thursday friday saturday sunday
five days and then you answer questions
but you don't answer all the questions
you leave so many things unanswered so
that means that if you talk about
information void
other people are going to try to fill
that in um i also want to thank you greg
i have
i will now start to use acehole and i
will never
be bleeped again thank you very much yes
i've got another word that i invented
i'll show you later so juan what did you
what was your take on the uh
on his presser today did he did he did
he do any did he
do right by himself or is he in the same
boat so to speak
i think he's largely in the same boat
greg i mean he's trying to explain
things i mean
he's right the total number of deaths is
the total number of debts but
there's no question in my mind that he
covered up what was going on inside the
nursing homes and we heard last week
just that from one of his top eight so i
mean
it's not like he could say oh that that
was a misunderstanding although she has
tried to backtrack a little bit but
i mean the fact is the fact i think
where i would you know
see this a little differently than you
do is i think the new york media
goodness gracious they go after de
blasio
and cuomo it seems to me i mean it's
like it's an all-out
hockey brawl every day i mean with the
tabloids the new york tabloids big city
tabloids leading the way
and the new york times loves to throw
you know some low blows at cuomo
whenever they get a shot
which is a surprise but again it's
democrats and republicans who are highly
critical of cuomo in this moment
over the nursing home situation and for
me
i just you know i i just think that it i
don't know that it's the end of his
time uh in politics but as a leader
right now
his base with democrats is in danger
okay no question
so sean you were in politics i am
interested in uh
juan's right though the new it seems
like the new york media has turned
but they kind of like waited until it no
longer would benefit trump
it's like now that trump's out of the
picture now they can now they can deal
with this because they know that won't
actually advance trump's
position or something like that am i
reading too much into it
no i don't think you are they wanted to
save uh como
while he was bashing on trump but the
bottom line is politics is really
actually very simple right
be honest with people we're human we
make mistakes and when you make a
mistake if you're honest and you
apologize and you're promised to do
better
um people will give you a pass but when
you come out and say the mistake was i
created a void
and i wasn't my policy that allowed
people seniors who were sick with kova
to go back into a nursing home
and infect everybody else it was
actually the staff workers
that actually were the problem i mean
you're not taking responsibility
and also they should have been honest
with the numbers i mean how many people
in nursing homes actually died
from his bad policies if you apologize
people forgive by the way
there's one thing in new york i'm from
wisconsin i'm out here this week and i
was walking around
it looks like a packer game there's
everyone sitting outside with stocking
hats on and
winter jackets what's what horrible
policy to kick everyone out of
restaurants and make them sit outside in
28 degree weather
yeah and also what's interesting about
the things that they're sitting in
are actually buildings right that have
all they would had to do was just let
the restaurant leave the windows open
because that's what they just did they
just build a second part of the
restaurant
and leave the doors and windows open i
don't understand this uh katie
where do you see his career going how do
you feel about new york in general i'm
very depressed
i will not go into my deep feelings
about new york in general because it
will take the entire show
um but i do not live there so i think
that your your opinion probably matters
more than mine but i think what's
happened to new york is really sad in
terms of cuomo's career
i think right now it looks really bad
but i'm not confident that he won't
fail up especially given the national
media has given him such a pass at this
point
i do think that these investigations
both
at the local level and from the
department of justice um
will maybe have some more results than
cuomo
would like it made it obvious today that
he's not going to help with those
investigations he tried to say that
subpoenas from the legislature
and the assembly were illegal and that
they couldn't use him
you use them against him because it's
you can't use them for leverage when
that's the entire point of those things
and when you have democrats demanding
that there be subpoenas issued
it seems like he'll be in trouble so i
think for the sake of the families
there should be some kind of legal
accountability here
because they're not going to get it from
the media and if there's no legal
accountability cuomo will continue to
rise
in his political career although right
now it looks pretty bleak
and you know what no one even talks
about de blasio
okay exactly i mean it's amazing i i
i actually deployed it was worse but
nobody cares because he's no longer a
national
a national candidate person he ran for
president remember that
yep for 30 seconds for 30 seconds he he
did
he did better than uh kamala though
didn't he just about close
did he say it after that maybe i don't
know all right